yes the use of synthetic cannabis is
widespread in occupied East Jerusalem I
had heard rumors that Israeli
authorities had been allowing drug use
and trade to go unchecked among
Palestinians to find out more at spoke
to Abu Musa a former dealer and user
recently gave up that life for one of
piety oh we're going to be a hot via the
stamina shake instead coke I couldn't oh
well couldn't I maybe on your hotel you
have select here
Wendell you have said come on octoman
here in this valley who would I be we
have a lot of condoms oh hell no
coefficient Nevada mr. Lobel Mosconi
over the stove ele horn now there's none
of this in the hotel they are efficient
amoeba coachman dude never the result
was uh I never saw Manny Muhammad it was
handled all the money in
I've spoken with two other Palestinian
drug dealers in East Jerusalem who said
they received similar guidance from
Israeli authorities stick to Palestinian
areas and they'll be okay cross over
into Jewish Israeli areas and that's
when they'll get into trouble
furnaces are hot rock Masood could throw
with illness which is true after all
I Sam Shiva Han is head of a mark to see
organizations anti-drug program he
showed me how the Israelis are hands off
when it comes to drugs in East Jerusalem
with this rebel McConnell but the CFL
did the nation' Amontillado Ottomans
money
Salahi dilemma side en su can be
re-written al-hilal moderato what I had
not a German hot rod vers la habra
aluminum valium optimally she cool dual
Alamut an amine model a bra a cerca de
la clé de la basura mode or nasha modo
Almohad Ratnam's Lusaka little Albus
little a yellow door Kira Kira I went to
the headquarters of Israel's national
police to raise these issues a foreign
media spokesperson denied claims as they
tolerate the sale and use of drugs in
East Jerusalem he said that when the
police are aware of crime they act
accordingly
whether it happens in East Jerusalem or
in Tel Aviv
in 2013 Israeli police crackdown on the
places where synthetic drugs were
produced and the small shops that were
selling them since then use among
Israelis has decreased but in
Palestinian areas like East Jerusalem
the drugs continued to be sold by
dealers on the street and experts say
their use is on the rise I needed
someone who could give better insights
into the government's operations in East
Jerusalem so right now I'm gonna go
speak with Ari Neeman as head of the
Jerusalem municipalities anti-drug
Association since Porsche pollution our
nationís Musa Musa Lucia limelighter
album Oh Janine well essentially from a
set of instructions new album a conveyor
belt of machine homelessness Shanna I
was in the Shafaat refugee camp we know
the problem is is terrific
you can see the children this is passing
through by the checkpoints but just next
to where this checkpoint is and you'll
see in a second you have the addicts the
drug addicts and the drug dealers who
are hanging out just right here which is
right next to the checkpoint isn't that
weird that people are going and using
drugs next to where the Authority is
instead of using it elsewhere and the
camp I mean but mostly lots of talk when
a hostile covert know myself toffolo
Mustafa Qadri when I get Matsumoto shoot
you may my name is Topher Lewis official
and cognition become name eco-mode
miguel economy show of the infinite
shampoos women's official i'm vanilla
mechanic little fat allahu la guerra
sook and me - I'm the faggot I'm
and as animals you say masturbatory you
consume the cornet value shoulder girdle